just when viewers thought that black
Mara Bandersnatch had given up
everything that it had to offer Netflix
just posted an enigmatic tweet that
teases one more hidden ending in that
tweet they state think you've seen
everything there is to see in
Bandersnatch try picking up the family
photo
twice naturally people in their droves
wanted to know exactly what happened in
this ending so for those who don't have
another spare two hours to retread
Stefan's journey I've decided to break
it down obviously there will be spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything just yet then I highly suggest
that he turn off now but for those who
go back and pick up the photo again they
will be treated to a dream scene in
which Jerome F Davies appears and bosses
step band to retread his steps and go
back to pick up the book forcing him on
the right path
the scene offers more than that with
Jerome stabbing Stefan which if you have
the volume turned up or make you jump
out of you see Jerome F Davies is of
course the creator of the book
Bandersnatch and is someone who killed
his wife in a brutal murder due to one
of the paths he picked it's a similar to
Stefan's path in which he killed his
father
Netflix jokingly tweeted you don't have
to it's not like we're controlling you
which of course is another nice little
in joke on the show overall it's a cool
little Easter egg that may not have been
with the retread but it's nice to know
that Bandersnatch still has some secrets
in it so what are your thoughts on the
hidden scene and did you encounter it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of the other
super secret ending a Bandersnatch which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who choose the right
path and hit subscribe so make sure you
do to be kept up to date with all the
latest TV movie and games news thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]